que je suis une personne normale que comme je l'ai dit
avant d'essayer d'être très familier autant
normale possible
[Musique]
un méfait avec la balle dévastée
il avait une vitesse de francs courts
qu'il a
et la facilité avec laquelle les joueurs ont été dépassés
[Musique]
il a toujours dit s'il allait grandir
aime jouer au foot quand
les garçons ne grandissent pas ils s'en soucient
sera le plus élevé pour l'esthétique par feuille
à cause de lui il voulait jouer au football
[Musique]
avec beaucoup d'argentins qu'on aime
beaucoup à maradona pour ce qui est bon
parler dans le village du monde
[Musique]
est
des forums importants est ce que cela signifie
mais bien fait plusieurs fois
que plus d'importance les prix
collectifs d'individus
[Musique]
19 000 enfants de moins de 5 ans n'ont pas
mourir chaque jour mais mon nom meurt
c'est lionel messi
et je pense que ce chiffre devrait être zéro
[Musique]
Comme je l'ai déjà dit, cela faisait de nombreuses années
Toute ma vie je suis arrivé ici en étant très
petite fille de 13 ans
Il se peut
21 ans
Je vais avec des femmes avec trois
Catalans argentins
Je ne peux pas être la solution à tout
Quoi
ce que j'ai fait dans cette ville à laquelle je n'ai pas
J'ai
qu'après quelques années d'absence
nous y retournons car chez nous
[Musique]
Oh